bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour une nouvelle édition de
votre journal de fin de semaine retour
sur l'actualité du jour et sur les
principales informations développées
depuis elle lundi voici les titres de ce
22 avril journée nationale de
commémoration de la déportation ce
week-end nous vous proposerons tout à
l'heure de redécouvrir le témoignage de
francine christophe déjà invité l'année
dernière sur ce plateau déportés à 8 ans
elle était notamment à l'honneur du
dernier film de yann arthus-bertrand
human en sport se dérouler hier en fin
de journée la finale du championnat de
basket militaire à maurepas après trois
jours de compétition le verdict pour les
corps armés engagés et puis comme chaque
vendredi donc le zapping de
l'information locale depuis lundi les
principaux sujets développés par la
rédaction
les nuits de boue à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines assises de la
ruralité dans le département ou encore
représentation du spectacle djihad à
trappes
on débute par cette initiative à trappes
justement où les vacances scolaires
peuvent aussi être l'occasion de
participer à différents chantiers la
commune propose son dispositif une
semaine d'efforts pour financer son
projet a ouvert aux 16-25 ans il
bénéficie d'une première expérience
professionnelle et gagne un peu plus de
200 euros sephora namani financer son
permis de conduire acheter de nouveaux
crampons nous préparer de nouveaux
projets artistiques comme pour hosanna
c'est ce que permet le programme une
semaine d'efforts pour financer son
projet pendant une semaine
hosanna fait partie des dix jeunes
retenus pour rénover les classes de
l'école élémentaire jean baptiste
clément de trappes contre 206 euros
ça me fait encore plus à coeur parce que
je me dis que bon les enfants ça va leur
faire vraiment plaisir de voir que
leur classe était vraiment rénover le
principe aussi c'est justement au lieu
de distribuer de l'argent comme ça peut
se voir sait vraiment qui est d'intérêt
public donc c'est une première
expérience professionnelle c'est ce
qu'ils recherchent
c'est aussi pour beaucoup travaillé sur
les savoir vivre le relationnel
ce dispositif instauré en 2011 est dédié
aux jeunes trappistes de 16 à 25 ans les
chantiers se déroule sur quatre jours
soit 25 heures de travail pendant les
vacances scolaires les jeunes peuvent
participer à des chantiers de remise en
peinture de manutention ou
d'interventions citoyenne dans le parc
immobilier des bailleurs sociaux ou sur
des bâtiments appartenant à la ville
depuis des années on a deux ambitions
sur cette ville la première ambition ce
qui fait partie de notre projet éducatif
de territoire avec une série de choses
un peu partout la culture le sport la
semaine d'effort des structures
socio-éducatives gta c'est ce qu'on
appelle un projet éducatif de territoire
la deuxième ambition conte avec et qui
va avec est un peu différente s'est
modernisée et embellir la ville 300
jeunes ont participé à ce programme
depuis 2011 et 120 jeunes sont prévues
pour 2016
la municipalité n'a pas souhaité
communiquer sur le montant global alloué
ce dispositif du sport à présent en
football la demi-finale de la coupe des
yvelines entre maurepas et guyancourt
c'était hier soir au stade du bout du
clos elle est morte asian mort nazis en
pardon se sont qualifiés pour la finale
au terme d'une séance de tirs au but le
résumé de ce match pour le moins animée
dans les tribunes par mikel ennemis dans
un derby sulfureux pour cette demi
finale de coupe des yvelines ce jeudi
laisse mort par auxerre au stade du bout
des clots goncourt saint quentin après
trente premières minutes équilibrées le
gluon courtois wav diallo fait faute en
position de dernier défenseur
arbitre stéphane freddy n'hésite pas à
carton rouge
réduits à dix les hommes de jute talent
morose on subir avant de craquer sur un
coup franc le milieu défensif de
maurepas fenaille questerre s'élève plus
haut que les défenseurs à la 43e minute
1-0 1re mi-temps qui était qui était
assez engagées des deux côtés il n'y
avait pas beaucoup d espace pour jouer
les ballons c'était difficile donc donc
du coup c'était vraiment assez assez
hargneux au milieu derrière c'était dur
donc là on a réussi à marquer ce petit
but juste avant la mi temps qui nous a
qui nous a permis de souffler un peu
à la mi-temps le coq de maurepas composé
d'une cinquantaine de supporters est
optimiste pour la deuxième période
là ils sont réduits à 10 je pense qu'on
va remporter le match haut la main et là
c'est sûr et certain en bas on va se
qualifier pour la finale pour les droits
médias au retour des vestiaires
guillaucourt accélère et se procurent
plusieurs occasions vont de marquer sur
un coup franc dévié par le défenseur
romain haas
un partout à la 75ème minute 2-1
mi-temps c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment me tuer il a fait une deuxième
mi temps extraordinaire on marque un but
on a clairement baissé le pied on avait
plus le ballon et et voilà on prend ce
but qui nous fait mal mais voilà il
fallait tenir quand même jusque jusqu'à
la fin du match pour pour aller chercher
ces penaltys dans la loterie des tirs au
but maurepas s'impose 4 1 avec un arrêt
du gardien antoine baptiste
on a eu un grand gardien ce soir aussi
charles félicité antoine qui nous aura
qui nous a quand même fait gagner demain
sur la fin on les a très très mature et
très très match est très très mal
ce reste l'envi de gagner l'envi de bien
faire et parfois j'ai pas de monstres ou
déçu un peu on va mais ça va compliquer
la mort pas affrontera li mais outre ap
en finale de la coupe des yvelines la
rencontre se déroulera le dimanche 5
juin à plaisir
c'était une première dans les yvelines
les championnats de france de basket
était organisée basket militaire au
gymnase mal me donne à mort tu as
également les matches ont opposé les
équipes de l'armée de l'air de l'armée
de terre de la marine ou encore la
gendarmerie au total une centaine de
militaires présents pour cet événement
pendant trois jours les militaires ont
troqué leur uniforme contre maillot de
basket à l'occasion des championnats de
france militaire la deuxième édition
était organisée cette année au gymnase
mail me donne de maurepas les matches
ont opposé les équipes de l'armée de
terre de l'air la marine et la
gendarmerie
c'est les meilleurs joueurs des
élections de la gendarmerie de la marine
nationale de l'armée de l'air et de
l'armée terre sont sélectionnés ont fait
des stages pour les détecter et après on
les sélectionne pour venir participer en
transmettant paniers à trois-points vos
bons donnent qu'une centaine de joueurs
venus de toute la france ont fait le
show pendant ces trois jours de
compétition c'est un tournoi qui me
tient beaucoup à coeur parce que ça me
permet maintenant seulement balade
profonde joue au basket dans le cadre du
travail c'est génial et ont su lui en
plus de pouvoir échanger toutes les
autres équipes où je connais évidemment
que la plupart des basketteurs là chaque
fois c'est un vrai plaisir de retrouver
tous les camarades
on m'a contacté et j'ai saisi l'occasion
alors que je n'aurais pas cinq ans
occasion comme ça de partager ce moment
derniers mois j'étais pas je suis
nouvelle
cette année et
oui c'est très très bas l'ambiance est
vraiment sympa est la mentalité très
sympa aussi à l'équipe de l'as bari n'a
remporté la finale contre l'armée de
l'air sur le score de 62 à 55 les
meilleurs joueurs du tournoi seront
sélectionnés par le staff de l'équipe de
france militaire pour participer aux
championnats du monde de la catégorie
la compétition sera organisée au mois de
juillet à san diego aux états unis
dimanche comme lors de chaque dernier
week-end du mois d'avril se déroulera la
journée nationale de commémoration de la
déportation à cette occasion je vous
propose d'écouter ou est plutôt de ré
écouter le témoignage de francine
christophe né en 1933 7 yvelinoise a été
déportée à l'âge de 8 ans vers le camp
de concentration de bergen-belsen à 83
ans
elle dit avoir dépassé la colère elle
donne régulièrement des conférences
auprès des jeunes dans les collèges ou
encore les lycées elle était l'invitée
de ce journal l'année dernière en avril
francine christophe invité du journal
pour nous livrer son témoignage sur
cette période elle qui a connu à la
déportation comment vous avez vécu ce
moment de commémoration hier à travers
la france c'est un moment difficile qui
rouvre des blessures mais malgré tout
nécessaire
non je ne pense pas que la route est le
blanc de blessure c'est un très beau
moment au contraire qui nous apporte une
certaine paix le fait que ça soit
reconnue c'est tellement formidable chez
venue tardivement et maintenant je crois
que c'est bien entrer dans les têtes et
lorsque vous entendez le président
justement de la république déclare et
l'antisémitisme et le racisme sont
encore là vous vous dites que malgré les
commémorations malgré les témoignages
que vous portez vous n'êtes pas la seule
mais que vous portez également il ya
toujours en danger
il a toujours un danger se fait mal je
rappelle toujours que hitler a dit le
génocide des arméniens qui s'en souvient
on en parle maintenant mais il a fallu
le temps donc on oublie tout ça et il
faut pas il est le week end une nouvelle
agression d'un homme de 53 ans était à
saint-ouen en sortant de la synagogue il
a été roué de coups traiter également de
sale juif
vous vous dites que c'est un acte isolé
et où qu'il ya matière à être inquiet
aujourd'hui on l'a entendue dans le
reportage une personne un déporté
également qui témoigne un ancien
combattant qui disait voilà aujourd'hui
moi je suis inquiet je suis moi aussi je
suis inquiète et il m'arrive d'avoir un
peu peur j'ai eu peur toute mon enfance
un bien entendu mais moment de
l'adolescence après j'avais encore peur
c'était en moi et maintenant il m'arrive
de temps en temps avoir un peu peur ça
c'est bien ennuyeux vous résidez dans
les yvelines vous témoignent
régulièrement devant les plus jeunes
dans les écoles pour raconter votre
histoire on va en parler plus en détail
tout à l'heure vous écrivez également
une petite fille privilégié et c'est un
souvenir il ya eu la fête inconnu mega
man vous avez rédigé vous raconter cette
histoire depuis longtemps les réactions
sont toujours les mêmes lorsque vous
parlez de votre histoire au public même
par rapport aux enfants est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le message est moins fort
et un détachement de votre auditoire ou
pas non c'est juste le contraire
c'est tout à fait ça c'est paradoxal
parce que toujours sous x 60 x est à
l'étude et c'est pas accès non c'est
juste le comtal les enfants sont
extrêmement intéressé il faut même des
travaux sur ce qu'on leur raconte des
travaux par écrit qu'ils sont
exceptionnelles et mon premier livre une
petite privilégiés qui est un témoignage
que qui est sorti en 95 mais peut-être
quinze ou vingt établissements scolaires
en france qu'ils ont monté en pièce de
théâtre un curieux ça veut dire qu'il ya
bien matière aussi à être rassuré même
si vous êtes inquiète aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas la seule source il est de ces
actes on peut se dire il ya eu les plus
jeunes générations il faut rester voilà
il ya autre chose c'est que notre époque
par la télévision
il n'est pas les ong y est pas tous ces
gens là votre père est prisonnier de
guerre en allemagne lorsque vous êtes
arrêté à huit ans et demi 26 juillet 42
avec votre mère c'est en gare de
rochefoucauld en charente vous vouliez
atteindre la zone libre comment s'est
passé ce moment justement cette
arrestation
cette arrestation a été fort dur parce
que j'ai 8 ans et demi et nous avons les
faux papiers nous avons un passeur qui
vient de faire passer la ligne
mais est-ce que les faux papiers sont
mal fait et ce que nous avons si peur
que
zoua dans nos yeux je ne sais pas mais
on nous emmène maman et moi la
kommandantur et on a commencé par nous
séparer et moi on m'a mise dans une
pièce avec un soldat armé un gros chien
je rappelle que les tous les déportés
ont peur des chiens avec des chiens
tellement dresse c'est comme des fauves
et puis j'entends maman dans l'autre
pièce qu'on commence à interroger et
j'expliquais l'entente qu'elle crie non
non non je ne suis pas juive non elle
m'avait dit tu sais fait très attention
si tu avoues tu seras mise en prison et
j'ai tenu le coup pendant un bon moment
malgré les insultes mais habitants et
demi c'est difficile et puis on a fini
par dire à ma demande que si elle
n'avait pas m'emmener donc elle est
internée dans plusieurs camps ont
finalement déportés gm 1944 à bergen
belsen
on va voir des images d'ailleurs comme
été tournée lors de la libération de ce
conte comment ça s'est passé cette
arrivée là bas dans ce camp en 1944
j'avais déjà qu'on a souffert en france
puisque j'ai avec déjà de prison et cinq
ans mais ce que j'ai découvert à berriac
gazelle évidemment c'était un peu
différent et c'était un énorme choc mais
en même temps comme j'étais une enfant
déjà habitué à beaucoup de souffrance je
les moins gelé plus avec moins
l'affolement que ma mère ma mère celle
des russes que je suis là ce que je vais
la retirer ma fille moi pas moi je suis
devenu un animal qui ne pensait plus
qu'à une chose manger un animal
justement j'aimerais que vous me donniez
ce témoignage parce que vous l'avez déjà
livré lors du 1 au président françois
hollande c'était lors d'une rencontre au
mémorial de la shoah au début de cette
année
cette anecdote on va dire ça comme ça
lors de la libération lorsque vous
arrivez en france et qu on vous tend une
orange six allemands il ya une dame de
la croix rouge d'abord la porte du wagon
sourire les gens font à une enfant
évidemment il n'y a pas d'enfant qui
soit venu si peu poignet qui soient
revenues des camps
lui l'enfant et ya une dame de la croix
rouge qui s'approche qui me tend une
boule pour toi et je lui dis mais qu'est
ce que c'est mais c'est une orange
bon c'est pour trouve que tu la manges
mais commence à ce moment
eh ben tu vas l'éplucher du jeu trash
c'est plus sûr et puis qu'il va manger
le fruit à l'intérieur bien madame je
vais faire comme vous dites je vous
remercie
mais les épluchures ne jetterai pas
parce que j'ai bien sûr qu'il ya
camarades qui sera content de les manger
lui il a fallu tout réapprendre après
réapprendre à être une enfant
réapprendre à vivre même si avec une
fourchette
mais mme savard nouer ses lacets tout
juste parce qu'on l'a pas précisé pour
le titre de ce premier recueil que vous
avez publié qui aujourd'hui adapté en
pièce de théâtre que vous pourrez
découvrir du côté du prisme le 29 mai et
il encourt une petite fille privilégiées
oui on m'a souvent réglés si c'était
ironique ça ne l'est pas du tout je suis
privilégié je suis en vie de gérard quel
privilège pour un enfant et puis j'ai un
autre privilège extraordinaire c'est que
j'ai retrouvé papa et maman
les deux mois les enfants pendant la
guerre ce qui était caché car il ya eu
des la france entière dans la france
entière il ya eu ce qu'on appelle des
justes maintenant des gens qui ont caché
des enfants mais c'est enfin le retour
de pas leurs parents alors que moi j'ai
retrouvé les deux alors quel privilège
jouant sans aucune ironie vous vous
estimez aujourd'hui privilégiée à oui il
ya une dernière question parler des
commémorations tout à l'heure vous êtes
retourné sur ce camp de bergen-belsen
bien sûr j'y vais tous les ans et vivait
la semaine prochaine c'est presque un
besoin
je suis chez moi quand je marche dans
les camps je m'assois par terre je
touche c'est un morceau de ma vie de mon
enfance que j'ai laissé là je suis chez
moi vous êtes chez vous vous êtes
détacher de la souffrance que vous avez
pu avoir
oui je suis détaché de cette souffrance
je retrouve une petite fille
alors après je passe devant les
monticules sous les monticules je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de morts
je les salue je suis pas folle mais j'ai
besoin de leur dire salut il est mort je
ne vous oublie pas parce que si je les
oubliés jeux lectures à une deuxième
fois
journée nationale de commémoration de la
déportation donc ce week end et nous y
reviendrons bien évidemment dans notre
édition de lundi de ce journal aux
horaires habituels comme chaque vendredi
à présent nous passons à l'essentiel de
l'actualité le zapping des principaux
sujets développés par la rédaction
depuis lundi et dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui le mouvement nuit debout qui
s'étend malgré les polémiques samedi
soir au pied est de la bibliothèque
universitaire de saint quentin en
yvelines plus d'une cinquantaine de
personnes étaient réunies pour
participer ou assister à cette assemblée
générale citoyenne on est là pour faire
pression au patron on est là pour
soutenir l'état la salariée entendre ce
qu'ils ont à nous dire entendre enfin
faire partager leur lutte aussi à nuit
debout
autre motif de cette manifestation c'est
ce prestataire en procédure de
licenciement qui aurait fait la
promotion en interne du documentaire
polémique merci patron nous connaissons
la fête de la bière depuis de nombreuses
années c'est toujours un grand plaisir
pour nous de venir ici tous les deux ans
il ya quelques nouveaux à s'être joint à
nous pour faire le voyage jusqu'à bois
d'arcy mais parmi les 50 allemands
présents aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup
qui viennent depuis de nombreuses années
déjà des habitants qui avait amené
spécialement 300 litres de bière pour
l'occasion plus de 500 contributions ont
été récoltées auprès des habitants pour
faciliter les transports le département
veut développer des parcs intermodaux
dans une dizaine de gars l'accès au très
haut débit est prévue sur un déploiement
commune par commune jusqu'en 2020 des
engagements pour répondre aux attentes
des yvelinois les directions prises sur
sur le transport sur le câble bas va
dans le bon sens pour notre ruralité
la phase de test concerne la ligne 414
reliant la gare de trappes à montigny le
bretonneux saint-exupéry financé à
hauteur de 3 millions d'euros par le
stif le syndicat des transports d'île de
france
le système vise aussi à améliorer la
régulation du trafic
pierre bédier nasser al-khelaifi se sont
rencontrées pour la signature d'une
convention liant le département des psy
li na la fondation psg un engagement en
faveur de la jeunesse qui se poursuivra
jusqu'en 2017
c'est une tradition puisque les yvelines
ont été quasiment à l'origine d'un
partenaire de cette fondation et à cette
tradition c'est la tradition de
solidarité
il faut que les sportifs de haut niveau
soit un exemple mais un exemple concret
mais lydie tu as donc succéder à alain à
jaja 58 ans est professeur des écoles
ancien membre du secours populaire des
yvelines prend la tête de la verrière
arrivée au conseil municipal en 2008
délégué à la jeunesse elle affiche sa
volonté de s'inscrire dans la continuité
du travail mené par son prédécesseur
prochaine nous tient à coeur tous autant
qu'on est au conseil municipal
on s'attendait à un choix parmi ses
adjoints qui connaissent les dossiers
qui ont fait l'expérience d'un certain
nombre de gestion de dossiers municipaux
on n'a surtout pas voulu être mangé mon
réalisateur avec ce spectacle met juste
en tout cas de pouvoir réfléchir
chercher à comprendre comment voilà
quelqu'un qui nie si en europe et à un
moment donné qu est ce qui peut se
passer dans vos têtes pour vous dire je
vais aller me tuer allez mourir en
martyr on est dans une guerre sainte
qu'on arrive à vous faire avaler des
choses mais que toutes les trois grandes
religions monothéistes condamne et après
ce résumé de la semaine retour de notre
séquence regard de jeunes sur
l'actualité comment les plus jeunes
perçoivent l'information locale et
nationale les réponses des collégiens
des sceaux l'a cuit en cours et de
giacometti à montigny le bretonneux
camille lambert et guillaume le squer
apparemment la france est étrange et 35e
sur 37 dans l'égalité des enfants à
l'école
on pourrait être mieux classé du qu'on a
les moyens on a beaucoup qui ont pas
accès à la scolarité et ça normalement
ça devrait pas être comme ça tout le
monde a le droit d'aller à l'école
non moi j'ai pas même sens et s'il n'ya
pas d'inégalités quand je pense pas il
ya plusieurs catégories en fait dans les
classes par exemple cas les personnes
qui ont du mal à comprendre qu'ils
s'investissent
donc ils veulent travailler ce qui fait
ce qui permet d'apporter un peu de
contenu en cours mais après il ya le
reste il ya les élèves qui travaillent
normalement
et puis il ya forcément toujours un
groupe perturbateurs un simple tu peux
avoir des bonnes notes et très méchant
avec les autres et en a qu'on est
mauvaise note et du coup ils sont mal
vus par sont moins bien vu par les profs
je pense que oui il faudrait peut-être
comme plus les encadrer parce que là on
leur laisse beaucoup de liberté
c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas les
encadrent un jean leur dire il faut
essayer de faire ça ça on les encourage
pas en fait tout ce qu'on trouve à faire
selon m des heures de colle et même pas
les aider quoi veux avoir des enfants
dire qu'on leur met des croix ils
sentent rejetés alors ils vont plus
faire de bêtises parce qu'il fait un peu
énervé si on essaye on se donne les
moyens on ferait aussi avec l'école
n'était allé voir un film qui s'appuie
sur le chemin de l'école ça raconte
l'histoire d des pays de l'asie ou de
l'afrique des gens pauvres qui n'ont pas
d'école à proximité et qui doivent
marcher plusieurs heures et parfois
risqué leur vie pour aller à l'école
ben a donné un peu d'argent pour pouvoir
fabriquer des écoles pour pouvoir avoir
du matériel scolaire plus de devoirs
pour ce qu'ils ont des difficultés et
au niveau du français des maths tout ça
est femme betty travail sur l'avenir de
ce qui va se passer après le collège
mais si on sait pas lire ni écrire il ya
plusieurs métiers qu'on ne peut pas
faire presque tous même
un mot à présent des sujets que nous
développerons à partir de lundi
l'association prévention routière dont
le siège départemental est basée à
viroflay à a lancé un manifestant ligne
zéro enfants tués sur les routes c'est
son objectif l'opération propose cinq
mesures dont une limitation de vitesse à
proximité des jardins publics et des
écoles mais également des bandes
réfléchissantes obligatoire sur les
cartables et puis également dans nos
prochaines éditions
le point sur les travaux du golf
national le parcours emblématique et de
l'albatros a connu de grands travaux
dans l'optique de la compétition
internationale ryder cup en 2018 son
directeur viendra nous en parler elle
d'ici là vous avez rendez vous sur
l'antenne de nos confrères de radio
sensations avec nicolas kirillovitch
pour l'hebdo politiques sont invités
dimanche à 18h karl olive conseiller
départemental il est aussi maire l est
républicain de poissy il a fait parler
de lui ces dernières semaines en
demandant aux médecins de sa commune de
limiter les arrêts maladie des agents ou
encore en lançant un plan de départ
volontaire de ces derniers comme cela
peut exister dans le secteur privé
écouter cet extrait alors ces deux
actualités ont fait la une en peu de
temps est-ce que c'est pas un peu un
coup de un coup de chance pour vous
alors peut-être un coup de communication
pour insister sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est dur d'être le maire d'une commune
face à la baisse des moyens la baisse
des dotations
est ce que c'est le fruit du hasard ou
alors c'est une opération de
communication de la part du maire de
poissy
alors coup de communication absolument
pas tout simplement parce que je
rappelle que la délibération est passé
en conseil municipal que je n'ai pas
communiqué dessus que le lendemain juin
un appel d'un ancien confrère du
parisien coup de communication sur les
médecins alors là il faut alors plus
qu'à la base je ne vais pas aller dans
les médias ça ait écouté il ya la lettre
est signée le 25 mars pour les médecins
elle est sortie la semaine dernière
quasiment à la mi-avril real est sorti
parce que les médecins ont choisi plutôt
de s'adresser aux médias que s'adresser
dans la réponse de cause dernière chance
pour vous il n'ya pas de chance moi je
suis je suis pas ici pour pour aller
faire de la communication je suis ici
pour aller faire et me battre ce
pourquoi j'ai été élu et que j'explique
dans ce petit supplément des finances de
la ville de poissy qui montre que en
deux années malgré 28 millions cumulés
de perte de dotation d'état projeté
entre 2014 et 2020
malgré 200 agents supplémentaires en
pas augmenter les impôts en 2015 n'avons
pas augmenté les impôts et en 2016 nous
n'augmenterons pas les impôts
c'est la fin de cette édition du journal
de la rédaction je vous retrouve ce
week-end pour une nouvelle édition du
café politique invité bruno myle yens le
président du modem des yvelines
également conseiller régional d'île de
france aux côtés de valérie pécresse
tout de suite vos idées sorties et
loisirs pour les prochains jours le 7-8
week end avec michael et demi d'euros